well what do you think though
is the solution to to all this team
mentality tribalism
you know this team red versus blue i
mean that's obviously the cause of
you know all the angst right now
everywhere i will give you that right
and it took me and i'll be honest it
took me i interviewed
and i think you should have them on your
show i interviewed the president
of the libertarian party of florida what
was his name
steve nicala is how you pronounce it
great guy smart young 26
really yeah his family owns the island
grill and ate wendy's and all this stuff
and uh
great guy and i'll tell you why he's a
great guy because he's a visionary
he speaks well and the views of the
libertarian party i didn't really know
now i was always
socially liberal fiscally somewhat
physically conservative
and when he went over the whole
libertarian party and what they were and
i had them on
went i was in the keys blew me away
and then i started researching it that i
spoke there they wanted me to speak it
then
they're what a big event the state of
florida in that you know
annual event i was one of the guest
speakers and
i liked him because i i told him i said
you know i'm gonna [ __ ] blast
everybody he goes larry i know your
channel bless
whatever you want yeah and he didn't he
didn't restrict me
in any way didn't even ask me what i was
going to speak about
i said do what you want that's liberty
that's why i like them when you ask
what's the answer
i think the two-party system sucks yeah
because they're putting you in a box
you know i don't know your political
affiliation don't care
your views is what counts right now you
should
you should have views that represent you
now of course you're not going to get
every single everything of what you want
but there's things in the republican
party i can't stand
and this thing's the democrat i'm not
more okay but not
the same as you and and and i think we
need to
uh uh
get away from i think another third
party is coming
because of you because of ryan because
the young people are growing up with
more open minds and i think you know
they say this
the republican party is [ __ ] up
because
they don't believe in the listen the
browning of america is here
love it we are more inclusive than ever
i have no prejudices in me
zero i just don't have them it's not in
my my makeup
the one blessings my parents gave me i
grew up in the melting pot
yeah we didn't give a [ __ ] you black
white spanish chinese
a martian if you lived on our block you
were good
if you didn't you wouldn't know what
block was that in the bronx
okay yeah yeah if you lived in that area
you were good if you didn't
you were no [ __ ] good i mean it was
just the way we lived right so we didn't
have those specific oh he's black
that's a lot of people from that area
too right they feel the same way as you
yeah i see
a lot of new yorkers aren't prejudiced
at all
because they live in a melting pot right
and you know i i understand
it you know growing up in it but i'm
hoping younger people
even when their parents were [ __ ] up
and they are some are
those don't hate it but they just grew
up that way but you have that open mind
younger
people and i think what's happened with
the republican party they're not
inclusive enough
obviously they don't they every it's
obviously abortion issues and religious
issues and
if you're not a [ __ ] christian you
don't want to [ __ ] hail the flag or
whatever the [ __ ]
stop it that doesn't make us who we are
what makes us who we are is how we treat
people and how we
are represented around the world and
stuff not
what you [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
what people pray to
or what they do that's their own
business right man everybody should have
their own
own [ __ ] uh say that's freedom and
that's
liberty right but they want to say no
we're free free free but you have to
[ __ ] do the [ __ ] pledge of legion
no you don't
do you wanna i do but it's i i don't if
someone don't wanna
good the guy wants to kneel for the
[ __ ] nationality i have [ __ ] kneel
what do i give a [ __ ]
right right i mean there's oh that's the
biggest
if that's your biggest [ __ ] worry in
this world that pisses so many people
off
and if that bothers you in this world
you got some [ __ ] issues
that's what bothers you oh our [ __ ]
father's fourth with a flag yeah right
to do that right
to do that hitler didn't let you do that
we'll [ __ ] let you do that that's
what the [ __ ] i don't get it man
but anyway i i think and and then the
democrats
they want oh give every [ __ ] thing in
the world away to anybody who wants free
college freedom
well who's paying for it i mean yeah
well we're gonna take over the world so
we got all the [ __ ] money and oil and
everything no
the education thing i can i can relate
to i i think
i do think that the education thing
makes sense because to a degree you want
smarter people
right that's the whole thing you want
less losers in your country
i agree if you do but but they have to
have it make
worth something and let me tell you what
i mean right when i was
doing my program with the court system
it's in the courts
one judge said something goes no larry
he goes you got to charge for that
more i go why he goes it's got to be
worth something
otherwise they won't understand it
they'll just think that's another
[ __ ] thing i had to do
if you make education totally free
mm-hmm totally free
now here's my green you want to go to
the middle
you want to serve the country you want i
don't give a [ __ ] if it's in the uh
if you if you want the government to pay
for your education you should have to
serve
in a voluntary organization for a year
two years
or whatever number like you know if you
go to israel
i'm not jewish but i know the countries
if you go to israel
everybody in that country has to serve
in the military for two years
everybody two years that's
given the national thing or whatever
they get paid for
other than that but i'm talking about
like you said with education
i love it i do believe in giving free
age first of all
obviously if you have the brain power i
just don't want to be able to obtain a
certain like
a certain sort of work ethic certain
amount of grades you can't just be
failing through college you get it for
free
that's what you have to be a go-getter
you have to be able to want have a goal
be like i want to achieve this and you
have to
and and in my thing if it or
they have a couple of things if you work
for
the government you know in let's say the
department of environmental
if you work there for five years no no
bill right
you know you have to have something to
make it worth it otherwise like you said
people are just gonna
oh let me go to cars and waste what's
the alternative you spend a hundred
grand
four years i don't like that you can't
get a [ __ ] job i don't like that
and i think it's stupid and you know and
we still need you know people often say
well that's because they get a degree in
history well it's okay to get a degree
in history i love history you know if
you don't know history you're going to
repeat it so i agree that you should
have but you have to at least
do something make it worth something
instead of just nothing and i don't mean
for just for you
if if you're asking the other people
because taxes pay it if you're asking
the society for pay for your good
education
do something for society i don't give a
[ __ ] if it's volunteering on the city
council boards or whatever
it's got to be something and then i'm
i'm all for it education
right i'm big on education even if you
just have a real a really successful
business you're
you're you're helping the economy right
whatever it is there should be some kind
of
worth of something yeah that's all i'm
saying yes
and yes but in the democrats say they
want to just give this
or i believe in universal health care
i do right i don't think anybody should
go broke right in this country
because they got an illness right it
happened
right but you get hit by a car [ __ ]
paralyzes you you're [ __ ]
yeah and now you're gonna just lose
everything you ever owned and everything
else
cause some doctors and hospitals want to
make your money you know i mean i
i don't agree with that but i do think
we need a strong defense